Understand
you were granted exclusive access
to the largest
ever joint military exercise
between the United States and Israel.
Tell us about that
Yeah, this joint weeklong exercise dubbed
Junior Juniper
Oak, is unprecedented
in its scale and size
and among its target audiences
for the messaging is Iran
CNN granted exclusive access
to the danger zone on the super carrier
USS George H.W.
Bush to see
part of the largest
ever American
and Israeli joint military exercise,
covering all aspects of warfare
from the air
on land
to the sea,
online and even in space.
The timing is no accident
meant to send a clear signal to Iran
and other adversaries in the region
that despite the attention
on Ukraine and U.S.
concerns over the new right
wing Israeli government,
the Americans
remain deeply aligned
and committed to a military partnership
with Israel
for the Americans and the Israelis.
These types of exercises
are a show of force,
a show of partnership,
and a way for the both of them
to show the world
that they can walk and chew
gum at the same time.
Only through a firm commitment
to this partnership
are we able to plan and organize
such an incredibly complex,
high end operation.
With so many elements across
such a large geographic area
against all aspects of war fighting,
some of which are seen,
some of
which are not for the Israelis,
the exercise is crucial.
They've long opposed
a return to the Iranian nuclear deal
and have argued
that a credible military threat
needs to be on the table to deter Iran
from fully developing a nuclear weapon.
Israel and the US share the same values
the IDF and the US CENTCOM
see eye to eye the threats on this area.
More than 6400 American personnel joined
1100 Israelis as part of the exercises
that utilize
more than 142 aircraft,
including these F-18s.
And while the Israelis
and Americans
regularly carry out joint exercises
this one shifted the focus
more on the offensive
rather than just defensive capabilities.
It also came together in just two months,
incredibly quickly,
especially for something of this scale
compared to the typical year
or so of planning.
While officials shy away
from drawing a direct connection
between the speed
and recent events in Iran,
and the breakdown
last year of negotiations
over the nuclear deal,
it is hard to ignore the context.
I think it's fairly clear
that we can very quickly
move assets
in the region to respond to crises,
and we can do so alongside our partners,
and we can fight
and conduct offensive operations
in every domain alongside our partners.
The military option
which President Biden
called the last resort to deal with Iran,
seems to be on loud display
Wolf.
More than
£180,000 of live munitions
were used during this exercise.
And one thing that officials
I spoke to today
pointed out to me
that was especially for them,
exciting and interesting about
this exercise
was really how it covered
absolutely all
aspects of modern warfare
from the typical planes and boats
and on the ground,
but also including cyber warfare.
And this time they said space.
Wolf. Very important.
Excellent reporting. I had to ask.
Thank you very much.
In a very significant signal
message to the Iranians right now.
That was the intent I got.
Thank you very, very much.